I remember when you guys did the Kobe
interview that was one of your first was
it like one of the first five or six it
felt like it was early number ten yeah
inner eleven it was one of the earlier
ones um you obviously played with Kobe
what years were you with Kobe I think
uh 13 or 14. so that was obviously kind
of some rough Laker years no well no so
I came right after they won the I came
when they were going for three p so
Phil's last year so so you were there
when okay okay so you were there kind of
like the end of like the peak yeah yeah
the Run was over
um unfortunately so you played with
Lamar on that team yeah Lamar Lamar
Powell buying them uh what's the locker
room like with Matt Barnes and Lamar
Odom at the same time funny and run our
test was in that muffler and run our
test so like people don't know Coke talk
big [ __ ] like I was like I I right when
I went to team because I'm someone that
just keeps everybody loose Matt Barnes
Ron Artest Kobe Bryant and Lamar Odom in
the same
it was fun you know what I mean and and
you know we used to poke fun to
everybody like there nobody was safe you
know and everybody get fun poked at them
you know what I mean so it was uh those
Laker days are fun man really fun yeah
what was because I mean Kobe is not
going on anyone's podcast a lot of
people have podcasts Kobe did do a lot
of interviews so you guys obviously had
a friendship that stuck with him and
resonated with him that was a very tough
loss for the world particularly L.A you
know obviously you know the world lost
but for La for sure
they lost a superhero you know what I
mean like
La got to watch Kobe grow you know as a
17 year old boy come to L.A what was the
one thing that you feel like
people don't necessarily know about Kobe
that you know being around him as much
as you were cool as [ __ ] like he's not
like it was funny because he used to be
on the bus and talking [ __ ] back and
forth and he'd be talking [ __ ] talking
crazy and we everyone would be busting
up I I remember one time thinking on the
bus I go why don't you show the rest of
the world this this side of code yeah
looked up he's like I can't show these
[ __ ] this you know what I mean
so cold the one thing like Coke was cold
like talk big [ __ ] was there anybody who
was too sensitive for his [ __ ] talking
on the team
um he used to go at pal pretty hard and
it wasn't the power sensitive but he
would just
that was just what I think his way of
pushing past buttons but he used to go
at pal I'd be like damn cold
come on pal let's go get me go handle it
you know what I mean so but but cope was
one of those dudes was just he he would
run through a wall so he wants you to
play as absolutely as hard as you can
have no fear in your heart and go to war
with him yeah I feel like Kobe's the
kind of guy that's like not gonna ask
anybody of anything that he wouldn't do
himself and I think most great leaders
are like that it's like you know I ain't
gonna ask you to do nothing I'm not
gonna do when he talks you listen he
doesn't talk much he used to he used to
hiss when he wanted the ball
um when he started hissing you better
give him the ball or make it or he's
gonna you know I mean stare a [ __ ]
hole through your body but uh
do just work hard man his work ethic to
me was second to nine you uh were a part
of another iconic team in La Lob City
years of the Clippers was special those
are fun I remember when tiger redid Rack
City yeah that [ __ ] was we took that
light by storm it was dope because
obviously you know I'd come literally
come right from the Lakers you know what
I mean so to see and you were you were a
starter on that team for most of that
run I mean you were very important I
tell people like I won a championship
with golden state and play with rock
stars over there but there's nothing in
the world like being the Laker so when I
went down the hallway to become a
Clipper it was just you know a team that
historically had been just terrible
god-awful even though it's in the same
building same city terrible man they had
you know Rays of Hope every once in a
while with d miles and Q and them when
they first came in out brand
you know Sam Cassell and patino run they
look they had but Tim Thomas yeah that
live City team just
captured you know the NBA by storm you
know we won our first uh the Clippers
first ever division title we were
beating the brakes off the left by like
record numbers like we're beating the
Lakers by plus 30. oh no it was crazy it
was crazy and you guys were stacked I
mean we were D like the the my first
year
I think our starting lineup with CP
uh JJ karon Butler Blake and DJ and then
Off the Bench they had Eric Bledsoe
Jamal Crawford me Lamar Odom Jesus
Ronnie Terry off
and I'm I know I'm forgetting some
people like I don't even remember Lamar
Odom being back on the Clippers I don't
even remember that Grant Hill on that
team I remember Grant I remember Grant I
remember uh weird like sports
illustrator voted us the best bench so
they did like a big old spread on our
team and I'm like yeah like we used to
give our starters work in practice like
for real but no that team was Op City
was crazy